في هذا
التصويت، عدد الأصوات
216، والرفض 210، وتم
اعتماد القرار دون اعتراض، وتم
طرح اقتراح إعادة النظر على الطاولة،
حيث أعلن بموجب هذا أن مكتب رئيس مجلس النواب في الولايات المتحدة شاغرًا، وهي
لحظة تاريخية لأول مرة
لأول مرة في تاريخ
الولايات المتحدة، تتم إزالة رئيس مجلس النواب
لأولئك الذين ينتبهون في
المنزل ويحاولون فهم سبب
عدم احتساب 218 صوتًا، بل يتطلب
أغلبية الحاضرين والتصويت
هناك 200.
426 شخصًا حاضرًا في التصويت
426 مما يعني أنك بحاجة إلى النصف زائد
واحد وسيكون ذلك 214 صوتًا
ولديهم Y لإزالة رئيس مجلس النواب مكارثي
هم
216 أه إنها هزيمة مدوية
لرئيس مجلس النواب مكارثي مع ثمانية من زملائه
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب بما في ذلك عضو الكونجرس
مات  غيتس أه من قاد هذا الجهد أه
يقود مهمة الانضمام إلى الديمقراطيين
لإزاحته من السلطة